well i spoke to david letterman about
you you did
i did wow i actually am like getting uh
chills on the back of my neck
i wanted to do this series called the
art of the interview
which is basically about the art of
conversation
but much more i wanted to speak to
people that i
truly admire and
i truly admire you
drew thank you so much that means the
world to me i i
you know i'm very humbled and uh you
know when anybody recognizes the show
i'm blown away but to hear something
like that from someone like you is
really special
what you have come on to the scene with
and been on the scene
for a while now is just
the most fresh concept
it's so exciting for people it's so
brilliant it's so deliciously
manipulative it's such fun
chaos the thing that really astonishes
me also is
you are the straight man
you maintain your cool you let
everything burn pun intended and
be the circus around you and you are
this
calm water conductor
yeah i would uh i'd kind of agree with
that you know like to us we just want
the hot sauces to be
a disruptive element but a background
character to the whole show like we
really
are a classic interview show like in
every sense of the word
and then this is just supposed to be
something to take a celebrity guest
and knock them right out of that pr
driven flight pattern but otherwise we
just sort of completely
ignore this absurd premise where we have
wings on the table and everything like
that
as someone on that side of it that's
also why i'm so excited for your show
and what you do because i can promise
you
with every fiber of my being and my
entire heart
right out to you people who have to do
press or interviews we are
so desperate for something fun and so
when you sit down for an
interview it tends to feel like you're
trying
so hard to be real
or funny or you know and you just get
this
i need an anecdote and the plug and
the fact that you have to earn your plug
on your show
is just such a you know what to
the system thank you very much and i
think too like even from your
perspective you know we have a big ask
when we're on this show because we're
asking you to eat a wing that's like
soaked in some of the hottest hot sauces
ever made
but for us we think that would be unfair
if we weren't at least you know
thoughtful and career spanning in the
interview because how are you
as somebody you know who has a movie out
how are you motivated to keep going on
in the interview
unless you have someone who's meeting
you halfway so like when we first
started the show
we didn't have like high aspirations for
the show necessarily we thought we could
be like a funny internet sideshow thing
going on
but what ended up happening is we had
this cult audience that was coming
every single week so that really pushed
us to make a better show
and then the other side of it was
thinking about you know the celebrity
coming in here to do this who's maybe
been
doing press all week and this is like
the 25th interview you know like
how do we make it fresh because
ultimately i think that
if the guest is kind of you know maybe
not up to it on that day on that show i
kind of look at it as my fault
so from like uh from being prepped
from being prepared for being organized
like we really take a lot of pride in
that and want
our guests to come through and feel like
that was the most comfortable least
comfortable interview that i've done on
this tour
i find your research so impeccable
and i believe you're a fan of howard
stern is this true
i love howard stern and letterman those
to me are like the two
best ever do it well i spoke to david
letterman about you
you did i did he said
that what you're doing is so unique and
so rare and such a conceptual
thing that people can get behind and he
uh he spoke very very highly of it and
you
wow i actually am like getting uh chills
on the back of my neck when i was like a
little kid
my dad would let me watch letterman and
i remember when i did like the first big
late night show i did was colbert
and you know you see like the ed
sullivan theater and all the things
about like how cold it is and then
you're actually backstage there and it's
all happening and then
a lot of the same people that like
worked on letterman like still work on
colbert you know but they just have like
normal jobs backstage they're like oh my
god that's biff
you know what i mean like it was just
such a surreal experience so like you're
telling me that i'm
like fluttering right now one of the
reasons i really wanted to talk to you
was because howard stern is such a
a guide to me on journalism and
you know he he used to torture me when i
was a teenager he'd have my mom on the
show and be like drew
call your mom and i was like oh my god
you are literally scratching at my
emotional achilles heel
on your smut show and you don't know the
history here and how bad this is hurting
me
and you're just all about sensationalism
and ratings and shock
and really you're breaking my heart here
and
i can't believe that someone i hated so
much
would become my journalistic icon
and i think he is the most well
researched
he asks the most personal interesting
questions
and he's actually one of now the safest
people to speak to
i think that he has like the best sort
of nose for what people
want to know what people want to hear i
do the show with a partner chris
schoenberger and
and we didn't yang creatively so
perfectly like i kind of feel like
all my life i've been looking for the
chris and chris has been looking for me
and they mesh kind of perfectly but i
think that
howard stern is like the epitome of that
like his sense his compass i'm like what
his audience wants to hear about is so
perfect
but i don't think that you can develop
that type of gut
if you are not a very hard-working
learned study or researcher
how do you do your research well like
for us what we do is we just take
advantage of as much time as we have so
it's like all right we hear that drew
barrymore is coming in in a week
all right got to do got to read the
memoirs gotta read the books
it's uh me uh chris schoenberger and
then my little brother gavin i've put
them to work and we kind of divide up
everything like who's taking podcasts
and like youtube interviews like who's
taking the books who's taking all the
magazine articles
and along the way we've found like a
couple little tricks where it's like
we'll really dig into the regional
newspapers of wherever that person is
from
because like that beat newspaper is
gonna cover them and know them in a
different way than sort of like
the national media and press like there
are little things like that that we've
picked up along the way or
i look at body language a lot so if like
you know i'm watching a drew barrymore
interview i can see maybe like a person
started to scratch at the surface of
something you want to talk about
but then they speed right by it and then
i can kind of see
like oh there was like an interest there
there was like a thing that like
almost caught the hook like the fish
almost caught the hook but didn't
so that's something then maybe i'll dig
in a little bit deeper and i think it
was just through the experience of like
doing the show for five years now 12
seasons and hundreds of different
celebrity guests that you kind of pick
up these little things along the way
these little hacks that kind of like
help you make the run of show but it all
comes down to like you're exactly right
is i think really caring you know one of
the things that motivates me is sort of
like
a fear of embarrassment a fear of
humiliation and i remember when i was in
college at the university of illinois
i was doing some like broadcast
journalism project and like boil orders
like here comes this person
from like the city government answering
my questions about boil orders and
they're just doing that because i'm a
student
and here i am i have no idea what i'm
talking about i'm wasting their time and
i can see it in that person's face
and i remember going home and feeling
like so horrible about it because here
was a person who was kind of just like
doing a favor for a kid who needed to do
an assignment something they didn't have
to do they probably just
believe in the educational process and
want to do what's right
and then here i was kind of like
disrespecting their time so i remember
like having that feeling and being like
i'm never going to have that feeling
again
and i think that that has you know
manifested itself in this show a lot and
then and then what ends up happening is
you know you become a victim of your own
success now where it's like
all right you do this for a long time
now you have this audience expectation
so you can't stop like you can't stop
doing it
uh but thankfully like it's my favorite
part of the whole process is doing the
research and
walking a mile in someone else's shoes
and watching the movies or like
listening to their records or reading
their books and stuff and it
it keeps things like fresh and
interesting because uh
hop one serves as kind of like an
extension of the guest personality you
know it's not like the sean evans show
or like the wing
show it kind of allows the guests to
fill that space naturally
what's so interesting to me is i so
agree with everything you just said
like i have my you know this is
just i but i study it so much that
i my preference is to never have to
reference it
but in my mind i know the beats and
where i want to connect to
but i try to let the conversation uh
dictate where and when i'm going to find
those ornaments the conversation of the
christmas tree and the questions or the
ornaments
um and i know i'm going to try to place
them but i'm not sure when and where i
just
have it all in here and the only reason
i like to fly
and not look is because i know i did my
homework
yeah 100 and then two i think like as
long as you have that structure there
that's great but ultimately like what it
comes down to is
is listening to the other person and
kind of going
wherever that thing's gonna go like one
of the things that i've realized is like
when you're doing interviews you're not
obligated to offer that much you're not
obligated
to give those answers and do those
things you know it's sort of a trust
exercise where i kind of have to like
get that out of you or like make you
feel comfortable enough to do it or like
trust me enough to go there like trust
the show enough especially like
you know you've kind of been click
baited your whole life like your click
baited like before clickbait was even a
thing
but now it's like something you have to
you have to like
be conscious of too and like in in the
sort of day and age that we live in so
i think it's important to have that
structure but also like listen
because if that person feels comfortable
it's like i've used this analogy before
but like a cat will always like let you
know where it likes to get pet like that
whole thing about like kind of doing
that with the guests and kind of going
that direction and
having and having that and having that
uh
i just i love that i have cats and i
know exactly what you're talking about
and it is a dance
it's a nuance and there's a great saying
that
nan i think she's like your chris so nan
taught me this quote which is
insecurity is loud confidence is quiet
and somehow with your amazing
journalistic
integrity and instincts
you also know when to step back and let
it happen and
go quiet well thank you very much you
know like
one time i was talking to michael sarah
on the show because it was a thing that
i noticed just from like these like
press junket interviews where it's like
you kind of
as the guests have to match the gigawatt
energy of whoever you're talking to
all the time you know what i mean but i
never want it to be like
you have to match my energy like this is
the sean show and we put you through
this thing like i think it's much better
to just
sit back and let people fill the space
of this studio like with whatever their
energy is like i think honestly
that's why the show has lasted as long
as it has because this looks like a
public access like 80s tv show set
it's just wings and this in this bald
guy but the thing that has made it
interesting
is that the viewer experience always
takes on the personality of whoever's in
that seat
and then when you bring in an array of
personalities then you have a different
viewer experience every single time so
philosophically that's kind of how i
approach it
but that is confidence thank you
may i ask how you came to decide to have
the set look like this
it was just out of necessity like we
didn't have two dimes to run together
so for us we were just like all right
like what's the cheapest easiest
like most simple way that we can do this
but then it ended up having
a like just an unintentional byproduct
of that is it made our show
more competitive like what ended up
happening was with this just sort of
stripped down
budget set we can travel and do the show
wherever like we don't have to have like
a locked in sort of studio thing so
you know we've traveled to london for
shoots like all over the country
we'll set up like we'll like rent a
suite at the four seasons
set this thing up and then charlize
theron when she's doing like her junket
downstairs can just take the elevator
off and do the show so
we didn't we at first we're just sort of
like this is all we have
but i wouldn't have it any other way
like i don't think this show is better
with a bigger budget
and this stripped down budget set is
what
has made the show what it is honestly
that's the exact type of work ethic
i have i will go anywhere i needed to go
i will get that thing i will do that
thing
i will show up i will travel i don't
care what it takes
you guys have this butterfly net and you
want to go
catch butterflies and if it takes
running across the globe in order to
find those butterflies well then so be
it
i love the spirit of we will do whatever
it takes to get it
yeah i think that i'm i'm obsessed with
like the process of making the thing
and then once the thing is made i kind
of lose whatever attachment that i had
to it
because you can drive yourself insane
trying to like chase
down or like define what everything is
or should be for the people who are
watching it
like do you feel that way about about
like making a movie is it like
uh create the thing make the thing put
it out in the world and then
make the next thing or how long do you
sort of like linger on it
i'm like probably just starting to let
go of things like in my 40s
but no i obsessed about everything i
looked in the rearview mirror about
everything
again nan i'm no oprah but she's my gail
and has been for 25 years
and she would always say why do you do
that to yourself make a decision and
never look back
you've made it you're done it's over you
can't even change it if you wanted to so
why are you going to sit and fester
and i'm like i'm just not as evolved as
you
are i want to get there one day i will
get there one day
and i've always known um that with all
of my
follies and growing pains and figuring
things out
i always knew to follow um
people that i would like to grow up and
be like one day
i never followed jackasses i had jackass
friends i was a jackass
but to me this moment is all about
getting to have
like a brain picking session with
someone who i've watched
as someone who is a creator and a
producer going
how did you guys nail this one like this
it's so brilliant and it's so well
earned and it's all yours and it's all
you guys and it is fresh
and it is so complex huh pun intended
to come up with something that is a
immediate straightforward idea
people think you have to go so big in
your concept to be big
and you guys had this clear idea
and that's where it grew from and it's
just so cool
well thank you so much like i really
feel like i could uh i could talk to you
all day
i know you're a little bit new to being
on this side of the table but
immediately drew like uh very warm very
comfortable like very easy to talk to
and i'm maybe not as uh trained as a
guest you know like i am more of a host
and maybe like part of me wants to like
keep the ball up in the air all the time
and like obsess and like try to
take control but this was like a a real
treat for me
and uh thanks for talking to dave about
me and uh
immediately you got a friend of me i
wish i wish the quarantine wasn't here
so just give you a hug you know
me too i know what it takes to carve
this time out
it's hard to make it all happen so thank
you so
much for making this happen thank you
sean
drew always got time for you anything
for you you can do this for as long as
you want to do it
you